Shure:  嗯楼上几瓶酒也是我放的
Shure: Hmm, the upstairs is really Chinese, really Chinese
Jake: 就是咱就不要做意大利面了
Jake: So let's not make pasta
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, do we have this?
Lucia: 没事，火锅我也会这个火锅大家应该都会吗
Lucia: It's fine, I can make hotpot, everyone should know how to do hotpot, right?
Tasha: 有没有这个活动吗
Tasha: Do we have this event?
Jake: 有有做饭的活动
Jake: Yes, we have cooking events
Jake: 没有做意大利面的活动
Jake: But we don't have pasta-making events
Alice: 很喜欢喝那个
Alice: I really like to drink that
Jake: 那可以做一个
Jake: Then we can make one
Alice:很鲜的
Alice: It's very fresh
Jake: 还是试一试吧
Jake: Let's give it a try anyway
Lucia: 这是一个
Jake: It's ugly, that's one thing
Lucia: 我以为皮蛋是一个地域性菜系
Lucia: I thought century eggs were a regional dish
Lucia: 就可能你们那边啊
Lucia: Like maybe from your area
Tasha: 没有有凉菜啊
Tasha: No, we have it in cold dishes
Lucia: 不过那个我也吃的很好
Lucia: But I ate it well
Tasha: 只是你没有主动吃它
Tasha: It's just that you didn't actively eat it
Alice: 啊对
Alice: Ah, right
Alice: 不知道够不够
Alice: Not sure if it's enough
Alice: 买几个吧
Alice: Let's buy a few
Alice: 让我写上我写吧
Alice: Let me write it down, I'll write it
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 你猜
Tasha: Guess, hmm
Jake: 打面糊
Jake: Beating batter, I suppose
Jake: 鸡蛋我看怎么会多一些
Jake: I see more eggs
Alice: 就是一个汤嘛
Alice: It's just a soup
Alice: 算是算很主食哎
Shure: It's considered quite a staple
Lucia: 咱们这里要买美分纸吗
Lucia: Do we need to buy some baking paper?
Tasha: 我知道啊
Tasha: I know, yeah
Tasha: 对哦画画的时候会用到
Tasha: Yes, we'll use it for painting
Lucia: 哦我以为是那
Lucia: Oh, I thought it was for...
Lucia: 那种就是美缝用来对对对
Lucia: That kind, used for grouting
Tasha: 也可以再多买点别的水果
Tasha: We can also buy more fruits
Tasha: 装饰在巧蛋糕上
Tasha: To decorate the cake
Lucia: 所以这个是那种
Lucia: So this is the kind
Lucia: 就是画布旁边贴的那个
Lucia: That sticks beside the canvas
Lucia: 对对对就
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah, just
Tasha: 是画纸上面贴的胶
Tasha: It's the tape you stick on the paper
Lucia: 我每次贴都不知道他叫什么
Lucia: I never know what it's called when I stick it
Tasha: 美文纸啊
Tasha: It's washi tape
Shure:  原来是我一直把它当成是一种跟胶带
Shure: So I've always thought it was like tape
Lucia: 类似的东西
Lucia: Something similar
Tasha: 就是纸胶布嘛
Tasha: It's paper tape
Tasha: 对对对嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Lucia: 然后就反正我看到是那个东西
Lucia: Anyway, when I see that thing
Lucia: 我就知道是他了
Lucia: I know it's that
Lucia: 但我不知道他叫什么
Lucia: But I don't know its name
Alice: 味精
Alice: MSG
Alice: 盐是不是有了你就不写了
Alice: If there's salt, you don't need to write it down
Lucia: 我看看这边这个箱子要不要收拾一下
Lucia: Let me see if I need to tidy up this box
Lucia: 这个是哪位宝宝的
Lucia: Whose baby is this?
Lucia: 好像也是某个电器的配件
Lucia: Looks like it's also a part of some appliance
Tasha: 嗯这是送的
Tasha: Yeah, it came with it
Tasha: 没有这个好用
Tasha: It's not as useful
Lucia: 啊那这个不是
Lucia: Ah, so this isn't
Lucia: 反正不太需要是吧
Lucia: We don't really need it, right?
Lucia: 啊OK OK
Lucia: Ah, okay, okay
Lucia: 我把外面那个箱子稍微收拾一下
Lucia: I'll tidy up the box outside a bit
Lucia: 那些不需要的我就扔掉了
Lucia: I'll throw away the unnecessary stuff
Lucia: 这个配件先撂这吧
Lucia: Let's keep this part here
Lucia: 说不定能用上
Lucia: Might come in handy
Lucia: 然后说明书齐了吗
Lucia: Are all the manuals together?
Lucia: 这个哎算了
Lucia: Alright, never mind
Lucia: 这个留一下
Lucia: Let's keep this one
Lucia:这个袋子 放在外面
Lucia: This bag, put it outside
Tasha: 在一个袋子里哎
Tasha: It's in a bag
Tasha: 那个袋子
Tasha: That bag
Tasha: 嗯被扔掉了吗
Tasha: Was it thrown away?
Alice: 我记得刚才见到他了
Alice: I remember seeing it just now
Tasha: 嗯哦垫子是吧是一个
Tasha: Yeah, oh, the mat, it's a
Jake: 对垫子是一个泡沫
Jake: Yeah, the mat is a foam
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 放放了箱子就不要了
Lucia: Put the box away and don't need it anymore
Lucia: 这谁的拖鞋
Lucia: Whose slippers are these?
Lucia: 哦这个倒是还行
Lucia: Oh, this is actually fine
Lucia:这个留着吧
Lucia: Let's keep this
Lucia: 这个可以不要了
Lucia: We can get rid of this.
Lucia: 把那些比较软的
Lucia: Put away those softer
Lucia: 和不好看的箱子收拾收拾
Lucia: and ugly boxes.
Lucia: 就可以扔掉了
Lucia: We can just throw them away.
Lucia: 咱只留那种硬一点的
Lucia: Let's only keep the harder ones.
Lucia: 对外观好看一点的就行
Lucia: The ones that look nicer.
Lucia: 有剪刀或者之类的东西吗
Lucia: Do we have scissors or something like that?
Tasha: 有剪刀
Tasha: We have scissors.
Tasha: 剪刀在
Tasha: The scissors are here.
Tasha: 这瓶水是我的吗
Alice: Is this bottle of water mine?
Lucia: 呃应该是你的
Lucia: Uh, it should be yours.
Lucia: 这瓶水是我的
Lucia: This bottle is mine.
Lucia: 可以拿笔在上面简单写一下
Lucia: You can write on it with a pen.
Lucia: 虽然有可能会被蹭掉
Lucia: Though it might rub off.
Lucia: OPS sorry
Lucia: Oops, sorry.
Lucia: 这些都是有用的是吧
Lucia: These are useful, right?
Lucia: 嗯这些都是有用的
Lucia: Hmm, these are useful.
Lucia: 这也有用的
Lucia: This is useful too.
Lucia: 嗯对我把这些那个就是没有用的
Lucia: Yeah, I'll throw away these useless boxes.
Lucia: 箱子就扔掉去
Lucia: Otherwise, they take up space.
Lucia: 要不然感觉有点占地方
Lucia: 毕竟咱们
Lucia: After all, we
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 但是就是我觉得就留这种对完整一点的
Lucia: But I think we should keep the more complete ones.
Lucia: 就行像这种就他比较烂的
Lucia: Like the ones that are in better shape.
Lucia: 或者说特别软的这种感觉
Lucia: Or the really soft ones.
Lucia: 就可以不要了
Lucia: We can get rid of those.
Lucia: 这个其实可以先留一下
Lucia: We can keep this one for now.
Lucia: 万一我没有用到这种长的那个啥好了
Lucia: Just in case we need a longer one later.
Lucia: 而且这个感觉还挺硬
Lucia: Plus, this one feels pretty sturdy.
Lucia: 但是很软
Lucia: But very soft.
Lucia: 就是啊他是用来插烤鸡的
Lucia: Yeah, it's for roasting chicken.
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it at that.
Lucia: 这边说不定还有一些可以用的
Lucia: 这些都就不要了
Lucia: We don't need these either.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: 哦这个需要热一下吗对
Lucia: Do we need to heat this up?
Alice: 哎呀无所谓
Alice: Eh, it doesn't matter.
Lucia: 对我把手洗一下刚才收拾了一下
Lucia: Yeah, I'll wash my hands since I just cleaned up a bit.
Lucia: 那啥
Lucia: You know.
Lucia: 这样如果需要弄弄盘子菜什么的
Lucia: So, if we need to prepare some dishes or something.
Lucia: 可以帮上忙
Lucia: I can help out.
Lucia: 要不然手太脏了
Lucia: Otherwise, my hands will get too dirty.
Lucia: 这个要洗吗
Lucia: Does this need to be washed?
Lucia: 这应该有纸我记得啊在这
Lucia: There should be some paper, I remember. Ah, here it is.
Jake: 来，大伙出去吃啊
Jake: Come on, everyone, let's go eat outside.
Lucia: 啊在外边那个桌子那里吗也可以
Lucia: Oh, at that table outside? That's fine too.
Lucia: 同问Shure: 摘眼镜吗哥
Lucia: Shure, should I take off my glasses?
Jake:呃，这个把这个植物摆出来就结束好吧
Jake: Uh, let's just put these plants out and we'll be done, okay?
Lucia: 这个哎我还以为他是个空盒开开
Lucia: I thought this was an empty box, open it.
Lucia: 这抹布
Lucia: This rag.
Lucia: 要不拿出去一个用算了然后就是到时候咱们洗碗就是拿一个新的
Lucia: Maybe we should just take one out to use, and then when we wash the dishes, we can use a new one.
Lucia: 我看看还有新的可以，我给它打湿一下外面的桌子有点脏
Lucia: Let me see if there are any new ones. I’ll wet it a bit, the table outside is a bit dirty.
Alice: 那个那个凳子也很脏
Alice: That stool is also very dirty.
Alice: 唉呀屁股已经上去了哈哈
Alice: Oh no, I already sat on it, haha.
Lucia: 我还没坐
Lucia: I haven’t sat yet.
Alice: 啊我早上嗯一摸一手土
Alice: This morning, I touched it and my hand was covered in dirt.
Alice: 反正
Alice: Anyway.
Lucia: 一直在室外吗？然后反正北京的风又挺大
Lucia: Have we always been outside? And the wind in Beijing is quite strong.
Alice:怎么感觉我这个头发好像有倒油
Alice: Why does my hair feel like it has oil on it?
Lucia: 我有个方法，就是离咱人这近的部分擦一下
Lucia: I have an idea, let's just wipe the parts close to us.
Shure:  那吃的不也得放这
Shure: But the food has to be put there too.
Lucia: 呃吃的尽量别挨着桌子呗哈哈
Lucia: Uh, try to keep the food away from the table, haha.
Lucia: 这个这个这抹布要不咱就放外边用
Lucia: How about we put this rag outside to use?
Jake:再录一点点
Jake: Record a little bit more.
Lucia: 然后我看里边还有新的就到时候洗碗还是干啥就用新的
Lucia: Then I saw there are new ones inside, so when we wash the dishes or whatever, we'll use the new ones.
Lucia: 谢谢谢谢辛苦
Lucia: Thank you, thank you for your hard work.
Lucia: 啊sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Alice: 哎呀倍儿脏
Alice: Oh, it's so dirty.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia:但是感觉一个抹布不够用 要是整个整个擦一下的话那我就干脆
Lucia: But it feels like one rag isn't enough. If we wipe the whole thing, might as well...
Lucia: 光把边上大家用到的地方擦一下
Lucia: Just wipe the parts that everyone uses.
Shure: 但是他真的很好用不符合我们的理念
Shure: But it's really good, it doesn't fit our concept.
Lucia: 因为一个抹布的话
Lucia: Because with one rag...
Lucia: 感觉可能擦整个擦不太干净所以我本来说
Lucia: It feels like wiping the whole thing won't be too clean, so I initially said...
Lucia: 光把边上大家用到的地方擦一下
Lucia: Just wipe the parts that everyone uses.
Lucia: 这确实还有还有仨
Lucia: There are actually three more.
Lucia: 那要不再拿一个用好了
Lucia: How about we take another one to use?
Katrina:  你不饿了吗
Katrina: Aren't you hungry?
Alice: 你吃吧万一
Alice: You eat first.
Lucia: 这确实还有还有仨
Lucia: There are indeed three more left.
Lucia: 那要不再拿一个用好了
Lucia: How about we grab another one to use?
Lucia: 咦真挺脏的
Lucia: Ew, it's really dirty.
Lucia: 刚才那个硕儿就是把这边已经擦了一遍
Tasha: We just wiped this area earlier.
Lucia: 这凳子是不是也得也得半圈
Lucia: Shouldn't we also wipe the chairs a bit?
Lucia: 让我看看这凳子脏不脏
Lucia: Let me check if this chair is dirty.
Lucia: 哎好吧凳子也挺脏的
Lucia: Oh, okay, the chair is pretty dirty too.
Lucia: 那边我把那两个凳子擦一下
Lucia: I'll wipe those two chairs over there.
Lucia: 对肯德基麦当劳新品好像国内外都不太一样吧
Lucia: The new items at KFC and McDonald's are different between domestic and overseas, right?
Tasha: 呃口感也不一样
Tasha: Uh, the taste is different too.
Shure:  停吧
Shure: Stop it.
Lucia:这些放着一会要用
Lucia: We'll need these later.
Alice: 哎是不是凳子不太够
Alice: Hey, aren't there not enough chairs?
Alice: 正好6个
Lucia: Exactly six.
Lucia: 但是那边那边的还没来得及没来得及擦啊
Lucia: The others over there haven't been wiped yet.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 这是没擦吧
Alice: This one hasn't been wiped, right?
Alice: 抹布在哪
Alice: Where's the cloth?
Lucia: 在这
Lucia: Here it is.
Lucia: 这这4个都擦过了刚才
Lucia: I just wiped these four.
Lucia: 那另外的还没来得及擦啊
Lucia: The others haven't been wiped yet.
Alice: 这根本就擦不干净
Alice: This can't be cleaned properly at all.